Thanks again everyone for being part of these classes.
We talked about building your world out,
deciding how you wanna pack things
if you're to use a one texture approach.
We looked at blocking things and getting them in play
using several actors such as blueprint
or even parenting and so forth.
We looked at all the different aspects of our tools
such as adjusting your construction script
and using Nanite resources in your scene.
We also talked about pack level actors
and level instancing as well as looking at PCGs,
how to approach all your different aspects of your scene
and your tools with lighting
and finally looking at materials
and breaking things down for tips and tricks.
I hope you've enjoyed this series of classes
and they'll help you on your journey
to build stronger, better, awesome,
even awesomer, more games.
Keep us all informed about your progress
cause we'd love to hear it.
Thanks again.